foreign
[Music]
back everybody we have new updates for
you in the Alec Murdock Saga the family
of boat crash victim Mallory Beach is
officially taking Murdoch in a
convenience store chain to court in
August the civil lawsuit stems from an
incident in February 2019 involving
Murdoch's now deceased son Paul the 19
year old was driving a boat in the
middle of the night while drunk and
crashed into a bridge at high speed 19
year old Mallory Beach was killed and
several other boat passengers were
injured according to investigators Paul
used his older brother Buster's ID
earlier in the night to buy beer at
Parker's kitchen a convenience store in
South Carolina beaches families suing
the franchise itself and the specific
cashier that rung up Paul claiming they
quote knowingly sold alcohol to a minor
Parker's Corporation filed a motion
earlier this month to throw out the
lawsuit denying negligence and all other
claims they believed that the store
clerk obeyed store policy by scanning a
valid ID and everyone entered the boat
at their own risk knowing that drinking
would be taking place the judge
ultimately guided with the plaintiffs
letting the case go to trial on August
14th let's break it down so Brian it
seems like the judge is siding with the
beach family lawyer by denying the
motion to dismiss the lawsuit what was
Mark Tinsley's strongest argument for
the plaintiffs and everybody remember
him from testifying in Alec Murdoch's
trial yeah Jesse I think the strongest
argument here is probably the one that
he won on and that is these arguments
are factual ones at least the ones that
the defense or the plaintiff sorry had
strong Arguments for but the other ones
that he won they were legal and they won
but factual arguments those are supposed
to be decided by the jury not the judge
so if we're asking the question from a
factual standpoint whether or not
someone is negligent it's not the
judge's role to waive facts and see
whether or not this law applies that's
where a jury comes in so I think the
judge was right to side with Tinsley and
say hey we've decided whether or not
there's a duty we're decided whether or
not there's injury those are legal
standards but this question of
negligence it's not for me to decide go
on into the jury now it's not the worst
thing for the defense they can still
potentially win this in front of the
jury if it's not in front of the judge
Terry what happens if the convenience
store loses the case what type of
penalties could they ultimately face
here you know this could be a a huge
loss if they lose his case it is a
wrongful death action and as Brian
mentioned you do have to show that the
store and the person who sold that
alcohol had a duty of care to the
customer and I do think they're going to
be able to show something to that effect
and they're going to be able to show you
have to use reasonable care when you're
operating a premises like that so I do
think that there was a duty to train the
person who sold the liquor and I do
think that that did occur there's some
evidence to that effect and if they can
prove that then maybe they can Prevail
the damages are going to be huge they've
asked for actual costs and punitive
damages and under the unfair Trade
Practices Act they've asked for trouble
damages so it could be a lot of money
the Ripple effects from the Alec Murdoch
Saga continue
the criminology student accused of
brutally stabbing four young people to
death at the University of Idaho has
officially entered a not guilty plea to
multiple charges of murder Brian
coburger was back in an Idaho courtroom
for a Raymond after a grand jury
indicted him last week coburger appeared
alongside his public defender Ann Taylor
as the judge laid out the charges long
crime correspondent Levy was inside the
courtroom and has all the details
this was the first time that we have
seen Brian coburger in a courtroom since
January and he really looked the same as
Judge John judge read the four murder
counts to him and the one burglary count
that he faces
[Music]
yes do you understand the charging count
to murder in the first degree yes do you
understand the maximum penalty yes Brian
coburger answered yes forcefully and
confidently when he was asked whether he
understood the four murder charges and
one burglary charge that he faces in the
murders of Maddie Mogan Kaylee gonsalves
Zana kernodle and Ethan Chapin
and Miss Taylor is Mr coburger prepared
to plead to these charges
stay silent I'm going to enter not
guilty please on each charge coburger
has the right to a speedy trial but his
public defender requested a date just
outside of that time frame
you're on our way to ask the court to
set this trial at the very outside of
the city child right we're not prepared
to do anything but asking for it to do
that today for now the trial is
scheduled for October 2nd of this year
prosecutors have 60 days to let the
defense know whether or not they will
pursue the death penalty at one point
judge judge got some of the names of the
victims wrong he called Kaylee gonsalves
Kayla that upset her older sister who
told a representative of the court that
it was disrespectful and getting her
sister's name right is important for Law
and crime I'm Anjanette Levy in Moscow
Idaho
all right I want to bring in our legal
analyst defense attorney Brian buckmeyer
former trial Attorney Terry Austin there
were some issues discussed after
Monday's arraignment including a motion
to compel Discovery co-workers attorneys
are requesting that the court order
prosecutors to tune over turn over any
exculpatory evidence the defense thinks
that the state has evidence that could
help clear coburger's name but the state
wants the defense defense to provide
more information what it thinks they
have since they've already turned over a
mountain of evidence so Terry the
defense team has requested multiple
items including all videos all lab
reports all interrogation notes and even
police training records how could this
evidence actually be helpful to their
case well you know Discovery disputes
they're always interesting to me the
prosecution claims that It produced a
mountain of evidence including over ten
thousand pages of written materials but
the defense claims that not everything
has been produced and specifically they
allege that the prosecution is holding
on to exculpatory evidence which could
prove kohlberger's innocence two items
in particular were requested by the
defense they want to shed some light on
their strategy the first item includes
the interrogation notes from detective
pain perhaps coburger said something to
the detective about something that could
help his case the second item involves
police training records I guarantee you
Jesse at trial the defense will claim
that the detectives failed to properly
investigate the case so no matter what
the judge decides the prosecution does
need to turn over in and all exculpatory
evidence otherwise they'll be severely
punished sculptory evidence that is a
big key right now one of the big
questions from today's hearing from our
viewers and also someone from our own
from our own producers is why would
co-burger choose to stand silently
instead of saying he pleads not guilty
well Brian is there any kind of legal
strategy behind that I mean if
potentially irritating the judge and and
others in the case is a strategy or
making them think that you're scheming
or not taking it seriously then yes
otherwise no legally speaking co-burger
pleading not guilty on his own his
attorney doing it on his behalf or even
judge judge entering on coburger's
behalf while he stands her in court
there's no real difference but in terms
of Optics and what is in the mind of
coburger it could mean a lot it's not
secret that in the court of public
opinion this looks like a bit of a
Defiance on Cobra's hand maybe the
charges and the proceedings will show us
more as this case continues though or
maybe he's just saying I might be open
to take a deal maybe I better negotiate
maybe I'm saying hey I'm pleading not
even pleading not guilty here keeping
his options open just a theory well the
investigation into the horrific killings
of the Idaho four has cost the small
area of Moscow Idaho a significant
amount of money the city's mayor says
that they're already working on a very
slim budget in the police department in
general takes up the largest amount of
that funding but now that the city has
stepped up patrols over time pay is
mounting before the murders Moscow
leaders had already planned a tax hike
to go towards City projects but instead
all extra money has been diverted to the
police department so far I Governor has
reimbursed the city around 93 thousand
dollars